So I'm going to show you how I build out
my model to determine those two answers.
We've already built out how to connect
to the hotel loyalty data using
the select tool and the create samples
tool but let me build out logistical
regression the step wise tool and then
show you how I interpreted the results.
The first thing I want to do is bring
out the logistic regression yet again
and we'll call this whatever we really
want to but I'll call it quiz logistic.
And then I'm going to select my
target field and the redeemer field.
And then choose all of my different
possible predicted variables,
not including the customer key, first
name, last name, and redeemer fields.
After this instead of bringing out
a browse after the logistic regression,
I'm going to pump this right
into the step wise tool.
I'm going to name this
model quiz _stepwise.
Then I'm going to keep both
the search direction and
the adjusted fit measure by default and
lastly, let me go out and
browse these results and
run the workflow.
Now looking at these results,
we can answer the two different
questions I asked you in the quiz.
The first one is which variables did
we actually remove from our logistic
regression model?
And as you can see, the customer segment
field income, years of loyalty and
income you we're all removed from
our logistic regression model
by our step wise tool.
And as you can see,
our R squared value is 0.6096.
So that's how I looked at the different
results from our step wise
regression tool.